welcome to part 5 of the dev white
series making apps beautiful thus far
we've built a an app that didn't have a
lot of love we modernized it we
performance-tuned it but what we didn't
do is make it look exactly the same on
older versions of Android as compared to
newer versions so just to just to see
exactly where we were up to there let's
look at our app on an xss running
android 2.3 gingerbread so we're just
starting it up and here it is nice and
smooth but if we look at the title bar
it's it's the old style there is no
action bar here it's it's you wouldn't
call this a very modern looking app even
though it's running on an older version
of the platform and we can do better so
let's switch back to the slides and
let's talk about backward compatible
action bars so there are a number of
options that you have when it you when
it comes to backward compatible action
bars two of these are the
actionbarcompat which is part of the
android sdk in the support library as
well as the actionbarsherlock library
which is a community effort and
much-loved so let's after having
integrated these into our apps let's see
what it look like on a nexus s we're
just going to launch that that version
of the app and there you have it you
have a beautiful action bar that is also
themed along with our brand so let's
just now bring it side-by-side with what
we have on a modern device and here we
have the the apps running side by side
on the Nexus S as well as a the current
versions of Android identical which is
fantastic so switching back to the
slides the action bar can be used on
newer version of the platform as well as
the older versions of the platform with
these backward compatible compare
the nice thing about both
actionbarcompat and actionbarsherlock is
that on new version of the platform
they're basically thin wrappers for the
native action bar it's not implementing
everything from scratch the other thing
we should talk about is the viewpager
the few pager allows us to horizontally
swipe across pages to bring you know the
previous or the next page of content
lets us let's see a demo of that on our
phone so we loaded the details page here
and you can see I can swipe left or
right and you'll notice here with
gestures I don't need to complete the
gesture in order for the next content
that come through while my finger is
still on the screen I can see it so the
view pager is a great way to page your
content and it's also backward
compatible so switching back to the
slides the view pager is also another
really nice utility class that you can
include in your apps through the support
library and it's backward compatible to
older versions of Android finally I want
to talk about the navigation drawer the
navigation drawer is a pattern that's
you've probably seen in many apps but we
have Android design guidelines that
describe exactly how that navigation
drawer should look like on Android now
you'll notice these screenshots aren't
from our bacon reader app and the reason
is is that we don't believe in
shoehorning these design of these UI
patterns into apps where they may not
fit so what we're going to look at here
is a another sample app it's not the
bacon reader app it's the sample demos
that come with the the sample code for
the navigation drawer so let's look at
that let's switch to our phone we're
going to load it up it's just a list of
planets but you'll see here on the on
the top left within the action bar it's
not the traditional up icon it's not the
the angle bracket pointing left it's
these three horizontal bars and when I
tap it these three horizontal bars will
actually animate in and out to show you
whether the navigation drawer has has
been expanded or collapsed the other
nice thing is we can not only press the
V app icon we can actually swipe bezel
swipe from the left edge in and also
swipe that navigation drawer
we can also dismiss it just by tapping
outside the navigation drawer the other
thing I want to point out is some other
subtleties of the action the navigation
drawer and that is that when I slide it
in you'll see that the content kind of
fades so we're making a concerted effort
to show that the that the navigation
drawer isn't shifting the content to the
side it's over laying on top and more
importantly the action bar is staying in
its place the action bar itself does not
move as the navigation drawer slides in
and out so let's switch back to the
slides and the good news about all these
subtleties that we're talking about for
the navigation drawer is that one we've
documented them in on the Android design
guidelines page for the navigation
drawer you'll see that on the bottom
right-hand corner there but also we've
made this navigation drawer available
for developers through the support
library now if you want to learn a
little bit more about the some of the
insights into why the action the
navigation drawer overlays on top and
what the the idea behind the fading
effect or the hamburger icon is tuned
into this Android design in action video
you can find it on the Android
developers YouTube page the episode is
called navigation drawers and they
actually interview the engineers that
built the engineers and designers that
built this navigation drawer so so far
we've talked a little bit about this
support library the great thing about
the support library is it's just
available as part of the Android SDK
manager so you can just go ahead and
select it and add it once you add that
support library to your to your app you
get access to a whole range of
components that are backward compatible
so things like fragments and we have
used fragments in this app we saw our
tablet layouts and our phone layouts so
in order to make this fully backward
compatible we actually use the support
fragments from the support library then
there's new patterns like the viewpager
in the navigation drawer we can't
actually in the android framework yet
but are available in the support library
and of course we've got our
actionbarcompat notification compat and
others like loaders
as well so the support library is full
of useful utility classes for developers
and pretty much there's no reason why
you shouldn't be using it already so
with that said we've come to the end of
the making apps beautiful series on the
left is where we started on tablets and
phones not a very modern looking app
didn't look like the the app has had
much love but through changes through in
layouts by including backward compatible
components as well as through
optimization techniques we've been able
to make it look beautiful perform great
and be fully backwards compatible thank
you for joining us